aranızda kendi işini kurmak isteyen
vardır diye düşünüyorum
kutlayacaksınız ama henüz size kimse
söylemedi ise bana söyleyin yapamazsınız
yapamayacaksınız
şimdi örnekleri vardır mutlaka
Eğer siz o başarısız insanları
tanımıyorsanız ailenize sorun size tek
tek gösterir
ilk kez işini girişimcilerinin dünyada
başarı oranı yalnızca %18
işletmelerin %90'ı ise 5 yılımı görmeden
kapanıyor korktunuz mu
korkuyorum Korku nedir gerçek Bir
tehlike ya da tehlikeye yol açabilecek
durumlar karşısında kaygı duymak hali
çok sağlıklı bir durum yani bize
tehlikelerden uzak tutar ancak
korkularımızın birçoğu bize bile ait
değil korku toplumsal bir şeydir
çocukluktan itibaren İçinde bulunduğumuz
Dünya bize nelerden korkmamız
gerektiğini öğretir
izlediğiniz filmlerden televizyonlardaki
haberlerden Hatta Dinlediğiniz
masallardan bile kendi payımıza Korkacak
bir şey mutlaka buluruz korku önemlidir
yalnızca korku değil korkulara karşı
verilen tepkiler de öğrenir
o kadar hızlı koşarsan düşersin Aman
oradan atlama yaralanırsın fındık geldin
mi çocukken bunların hiçbirinden
korkmazken bize bunlardan korkmamız
gerektiği öğretildi
ve bu korkulara karşı vermemiz gereken
tepkide yapma
cesaret isteği korkunun varlığından
meydana gelir korkunun olmadığı bir
yerde cesaretten söz edemeyiz
girişimciler için cesaret korkunun
yokluğu değil korkuya rağmen devam
etmeye yeteneğidir
her da dolarlık şirketini kurarken
korkup korkmadığını sormuşlar her gün
demiş çünkü başarısız olsaydım bundan
pek çok hayata etkilenirdi
sizi
geri tutabilir ya da maliyet
[Alkış]
başarısızlık korkusu karşısında
girişimden Uzak durabilirsiniz ya da bu
sizi daha çok çalışmayı motive edebilir
başarı kavramı değişmekle birlikte
başarı için çalışmamak benim için çok
büyük bir lüks Benim başka bir şansım
yoktu Ben mecburdum
kendime tanıtırken hayatımdaki muhteşem
iki kadından bahsetmeden olmaz Öncelikle
kendi bilmese de benim annem çok güçlü
bir kadın
onun arkasından babasını hemen
arkasından da hayattaki tek dayanamalı
annesini kaybetmiş
Benim annem hayatı boyunca hep korktu
benim mücadele etti kendince
hayatımdaki diğer muhteşem kadın ise
ablam dünyanın en çalışkan insanı
olabilirken kendisi lise sınavına bile
hazırlanırken gecenin üçünde kalkar ders
çalışır
okula gider ve yeniden ders çalışır
çok başarılı bir öğrenciciydi ve bir
hayali vardı Psikoloji okumak
akademisyen olmak başardı da
böyle çalışkan bir ablamın kardeş olarak
hayatın boyunca hep onu örnek aldım
başarılı bir öğrencilik dönemim oldu Bir
de bir başla o zaman elalemin bana bir
etiketi vardı cinsiyetçi bir etki erkek
Fatma
Korkmaz sözümüz takılmaz
suya tuttuğunu koparır Oysa Bana kalırsa
küçücük ayarları olan küçük bir kız
çocuğuydum ben evimin altında bir
pastane vardı
Büyüdün de ne olacaksın diye
sorduklarında o pastanede çalışmayı
isterdim
hastane açmak falan değil o pastanede
çalışmayı istiyordum
okuldan eve geliyorum metininde sıra
sıra çikolatalar Çikolatalı pasta var
onları izliyorum ve kendimi eve atıyorum
hemen mutfakta buluyorum kendimi
romantik filmlerde yaygın bir tipleme
vardır yani mutlu olur çikolata yer
mutsuz olur çikolata yer o benim en çok
da korktuğum anda kendimi mutfakta
buluyorum
ilkokul lise derken üniversite giriş
sınavında derece yaptım Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi İşletme bölümünü kazandım
Hatta hayatım boyunca da hep çalıştım
Yeri geldi palyaço'luk yaptım Yeri geldi
garsonluk
henüz mezun olmadan
bir iş buldum kendime bir televizyon
kanalında
pazarlama departmanında çalışıyorum ve
böyle gecem
gündüzümü belirsizlik korkusu
Ben biliyoruz değiştirirsek kim bilir
nasıl olacak
karar ver
di bana hayatımın geri kalanıyla ilgili
ne yapmak istediğimin hakkında en ufak
bir fikrim dahi yoktu işi bıraktım
Hollanda working vardı ona başvurdum
bir hafta içinde vizem geldi İstanbul'da
yaşadığım evin eşyalarını sattım
ve ailemin karşısına da girdim ben
gidiyorum Yeni Zelanda'ya
karşılaştığı
tepki anneme kadın başına bu hayattan
korkması gerekiyor öğretilmişti
valizde sadece eşyaların
net almaya ve kalacağım 10 günlük geri
ayarlamaya yetecek paramla Yeni
Zelanda'ya doğru yola
devamında da kaldığım pansiyonda
katçılık yaparak başladım bir şey çarşaf
değiştirdim temizlik yaptım Hayatımın en
mutlu ve özgür döneminde diyebilirim
başarı kaygım yok Kariyerim ne olacak
başarısız olursam Elalem ne diyecek
hiçbir kaygı duymuyorum
Zelanda da bulabildiğim her İşte
çalıştım bir köpek yemi fabrikasını daha
fırın paketledim hemen arkasından bir
yemek fabrikasının daha operatörü oldum
Daha sonrasında bir de Lojistik
merkezinde depo sorumlusu oldu
dedim ya ben bir çikolata düşkünüyüm
diye cebimde son kuruşum dahi olsa
çikolata yerim Yeni Zelanda'da
bulunduğum süreç boyunca da bütün
çikolataların tadına baktım ve bir şey
fark ettim bütün çikolatalar farklı
satıyordu Türkiye'de yediğimiz bütün
çikolatalar hangi markanın olursa olsun
Aynı lezzete sahip yani içerisinde
Kuru ve bir duvar çikolatayla o zaman
tanıştım
bir belirttim
tam Tutkun Ve ben bunu acaba bir mesleğe
dönüşebilir dönüştürebilir miyim diye
daha önce birlikte çalıştığım bu tarz
açtım fikrimi yeni zelanda'dan dönmeyi
düşünüyorum
ama boyunca turizmde çalışmış bir adam
maraton koşuyor ve ekmeğinden
çikolatasını her şeyini kendi yapıyordum
daha işletmeliyiz kuruma hayali
anlatıyorum ona fikrimi
bakmak çıkmak konusunda tecrübeli
girişimci bir adam onu anlatıyorum
fikrimi ve bana diyor ki Hani dedim ya
bize korkmamız öğretilir diye korkma
Bizim de korktuğun
ne varsa bugün hayatında yok
et ve yarım daha büyük sıkıntılara
bırakacak sermayem yok Korkma birçok
insanda olmayan
bir şeyim var gençliğin zamanın ve
donanımını tamam diyorum
ailemin karşısına geçiyorum ben de
hayatımın geri kalanıyla ilgili yapmam
gereken şeyi buldum ben bir iş kuracağım
bir çikolatacı olacağım
üstüne yapamazsın
kandırılırsın o kadar güzel bir
üniversite mezunsun istediğ
in şeylerden fark
ettim ben de Vazgeçiyorum
Buradan değil işi aileme söylemekten
ben korkularıma karşı yapamam dememeyi
tercih ettim yapamayacağım görmem lazım
bir cevabım var
yapamazsam yeniden başlarım bugün 27
yaşında
bu işi kurarken bildiğimden çok daha
fazlasını biliyorum cebimde muhteşem bir
deneyim var
daha yaparım ve bu sefer daha güzelini
yaparım
Hani işi garajda kurma hikayesi vardır
ya benim hikayemde biraz öyle
zekeriyaköy'de kurdum Ben işimi
Zekeriyaköy O zaman böyle popüler bir
yer değil ve İstanbul'da kiraların en
uygun olduğu bir yer bir müstakil bina
tuttum Üst katında yaşıyorum alt katında
ise üretim yapıyorum
neler yapabilirim diye Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi
ofisleri alıştırmalık işi var sen yapar
mısın dedim yaparım
Kiram ve faturalarımın karşılayabilmek
için öncelikle atıştırmalık üreterek
başladım
Günde 70 kilo Hamur yoğuruyorum makinem
falan yok elimle evde bir fırında
kurabiye pişiriyorum yükleniyorum onları
gidiyorum satıyorum ve
geri dönüyorum
bu şekilde hayatımı idame ettirmeye
çalışıyorum Bu atıştır
malıklarımızdan taşarak insanlar Tadım
yaptırmaya başladım
ve çok güzel tepkiler aldım 5 günlük
etkinliklerde götürdüğüm çikolatalarım
ilk gün öğlen olmadan bitiyordu dedim ki
ben bu işi bir adım daha ileriye taşımam
lazım
ve cesaret ettim 50 bin TL kadın
girişimci kredisi kullanarak bir dükkan
tuttum
dükkanın hijyenik koşullarını sağladım
üretime hazır hale getirdim kapasitemi
büyütmek ama makine alacak param
kalmamış
Sizleri aradım
Ben böyle böyle bir şey yapmak istiyorum
param yok onlar da geldiler beni ben
hayallerimi anlatıyorum ama gerçeklerim
hayallerimden çok farklı
bana aklımın ucundan geçmeyecek ödeme
kolaylıklarıyla daha beni istemeden
makineleri gönderdiler Onlar da benim
hikayeme inanmıştı
hep dedim sattım o makinelerin borcumu
kapattım yeni bir makine sipariş verdim
ve birlikte
hastayız ve hala öyle biliyoruz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
ben bu hikayeyi daha önce başka bir
yerde anlattığımda aldığım tepkiler
böyle şeyleri mümkün olmayacak Hani o
kadar iyi insanlar karşınıza çıkmaz
fırsatlar karşınıza çıkmaz yönündeydi
biri bana başlarken bunu anlatsa Ben de
derdim Hani biraz apartılmış bir hikaye
ya bu diye Ancak
şunu söylemeliyim ben evde çikolata
yaparken keşfedilmedim yola çıktım
onlarca kapı çaldım kimsenin kabul
etmediği işleri kabul ettim ve günlerce
uykusuz kaldım
bayramımızda binlerce kutu sipariş
hazırladık Ramazan boyunca yalnızca
sahurla iftar saatleri arasında kalan bu
işten
kaldırırsan bayramında binlerce kutu
hazırlayarak müşterilerimize hizmet
veriyoruz
ya da ihracat yapmaya başladım Onun
Hikayesi de şöyle Ramazan'da o kadar
çalışmışım yorgunum Ramazan Bayramı'nda
ailemin yanına gidiyorum
diye
ben Daha valizimi açmadan
İstanbul'a döndüm Dükkan açtım Başka
çikolatacıların kabul etmediği şey
yetişmez diyerek kabul etmediği şey
kapasitemizin çok çok üstünde olmasına
rağmen kabul ettim ve 3 gün içinde
teslim ettim hani yapamam demeyi
sevmiyorum Dedim ya bundan daha çok
önemsediğim bir şey var verdiğim sözü
yerine getirmek
şimdi sorumluluklarım kendimle sınırlı
değil benimle birlikte emek veren
onlarca insana
tedarikçimizden tüketicimize binlerce
kişiye karşı sorumluluklarım var Ve
şimdi daha çok korkuyorum
her şey
iyi bir şeyi yapıyorum daha çok
çalışıyorum
adil bir yerde değil
hepimiz aynı şeyi Uğraşmak için başka
başka çabaları harcıyoruz
görünüyor
mu ve buna değiyor
yapamazsınız değil yaparsınız çok zor
olacak
canımız çok yanacak Ancak bu acıya
değecek tutkunuzu bulup korkmadan değil
korkularınıza rağmen yola çıkın Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]